[Música]
y
sí
ah
y
buenas como andan
como les contaba usted un ra me lo de la
vega su economista gestión en finanzas
soy emprendedor fintech soy fundador y
sido de veras y hoy vamos a hablar de
finanzas de tecnología pero sobre todo
de inclusión financiera para cambiar hoy
su mañana
en latinoamérica y en argentina la
inclusión financiera es horrible
pensando en inclusión financiera más
allá de cuánta gente tiene en cuenta
bancarizada no cuenta el banco o no en
argentina 2 de cada 10 personas usan
algún tipo de institución financiera
para ahorrar si de esas dos con suerte
un en 15 114 va al mercado de capitales
a colocar sus ahorros
eso significa haciendo números rápidos
en una nación con 44 millones de
habitantes que sumamos a todos los
inversores sin importar su tamaño
todas las personas geniales que
invierten se sumamos a todas las
empresas que invierten y todas que
algunos invirtieron en el último tiempo
juntamos algo así como 400 mil cuentas
menos el 1% de la población de este país
por otro lado si juntamos una parte muy
chiquita nuestra población jóvenes
profesionales quiénes son ustedes o
pueden ser el día de mañana gente entre
25 y 35 años agarramos el 10% más rico
solamente en ese conjunto de gente
280 mil personas que podrían llevar
todos los años al mercado capitales 50
mil millones de pesos que podrían
financiar nuevos proyectos que podrían
agregar valor que podrían generar
trabajo no lo hacen porque básicamente
hay dos barreras gigantes una de parte
de los inversores de los clientes y una
de parte de los brokers de esas personas
que pueden asesorar que los pueden
ayudar
de parte de los clientes es fácil pensar
los ponemos en sus zapatos y tenemos que
empezar por el ahorro es el gran
problema del yo hoy contra el mañana voy
a agarrar mi sueldo y gastarlo hoy os lo
voy a guardar para gastarlo más adelante
tiene sentido ahorrar lo cuando ese
dinero se lo comí inflación y
devaluación la verdad que no tanto
entonces a veces tiene mucho sentido
hablando económicamente así me lo quemó
este fin de semana y ya
a aquellos que sin embargo dice bueno de
todas maneras voy a borrar probablemente
que analicen esos ahorros a través de
algún tipo de institución financiera que
conocemos todos un poco entonces qué
hacemos vamos depositamos un plazo fijo
y ese banco nos paga a un 35 40 por
ciento digamos somos generosos y el
banco se ha vuelta y se lo presta una
empresa que fabrica a un ser que
construye una empresa que cosecha y se
lo presta el 70% por decir algo se queda
de por medio con una una parte enorme de
diferencia siguiente en 1346 70 porque
son re avaros bueno puede ser pero
aparte porque el sistema financiero es
una estructura gigante imagínense por
cada banco que ustedes conozcan hay un
edificio en buenos aires hay un montón
de casas centrales en cada ciudad del
país y un montón de sucursales en los
barrios interior hay cada uno de esos
lugares tiene su gerente su jefe de área
su oficial de cuentas y esto tiene un
costo enorme evidentemente hay que
pagarlo
el costo hay un lugar que es muchísimo
más eficiente para asignar estos
recursos hay un lugar que es el mercado
de capitales la famosa bolsa que todos
tenemos en donde aquellas personas que
tiene plata para invertir plata ahorrada
se puede encontrar directamente con
aquella persona que la necesito para
generar valor y que qué pasa no este es
intermediario de la región simplemente
de asesores que aconsejan a uno cómo
invertir el concejal a otro cómo captar
esas inversiones consecuentemente esta
brecha que había recién entre el 30 35
65 70 se achica muchísimo y esa
asignación es mucho más eficiente las
empresas pagan menos ustedes pagan más
ahora
porque porque no han básicamente porque
no sabe cómo hacerlo tiene miedo y sobre
el miedo se creen un montón de
prejuicios quien piensa que la bolsa es
pura especulación quien piensa que la
bolsa de una timba quien piensa que es
poco más que jugar a la ruleta bueno la
verdad es que de bolsa están muy lejos
de hacer eso en realidad del mercado
capitales es un lugar en donde tenemos
instrumentos para cuidarnos de esos
males que como argentinos nos castigan y
otras años para cuidarnos de la
inflación y cuidarnos de la devaluación
hagamos un ejercicio muy sencillo dos
amigos los compañeros del cole empiezan
a ahorrar mil pesos por mes mil pesos
por mes en un año tienen
doce mil pesos en diez años tienen 120
mil pesos vamos en cuenta que el que
ahorró 120 mil pesos en diario se puede
comprar un par de partidos va a ser
contento
por otro lado es otro amigos hay un poco
más de finance y todos los años todos
los meses esos mil pesos lo metían en el
mercado capitales lo invertí en lo que
lo cubre la inflación y que le generaba
un interés a lo largo de esos 120 meses
ese esa persona va a tener unos 20 mil
va a tener un millón 400 mil pesos
hay una diferencia de 12 a 1 entre la
persona que guarda su dinero debajo del
colchón y la persona que lo invierte el
mercado capitales eso es inclusión
financiera porque por más que uno lo
noten una persona va a ser 12 veces más
rica que la otra ahora capaz que esto
parece híper teórico traído de un libro
y el gorro playero vamos a un ejemplo
súper argentino
el argentino nos encanta por ejemplo
comprar auto planes él se puso a remo
hace un tiempo atrás no olvidemos por un
segundo de cuánto cuesta terminar de
patentar el auto cuánto cuesta sacarlo
tratar de vender otro plan no importa
todos sabemos que el auto que os guste
empieza a subir de precio todos los
meses entonces era difícil alcanzarlo
con un auto plan que hacemos
los meses como un pedacito el auto
compramos la rueda compramos lo adelanté
compramos el asiento y así todos los
meses un pedacito de ese auto ya nuestro
si ahora qué pasaría si no tenemos que
esperar los 84 benditos meses que tiene
un auto plan y agarramos todos los meses
y invertimos nuestro dinero esa cuota en
algo que proteja el valor de nuestro
capital que se mueva como se mueve
precio el auto y qué imagen de interés
que trabaje para nosotros y no para que
no estaba en el auto bueno nos
encontraríamos con tener un script amos
84 meses para comprar el auto
necesitamos 67 más o menos nos agarramos
un 20 por ciento del tiempo o si lo
quieren de otra manera al final del
camino el final de los 84 meses
tendremos algo así como un 40 por ciento
más de dinero
queríamos comprarnos un base y
terminamos con un full
ahora esto que lo sabe cualquier que sea
un poco de finanzas porque esos dije por
qué no transmite porque estos números
saben porque esto no está haciendo esto
bueno porque comentar esto y llevar esto
práctica y asesorar una persona yo el
tiempo esos brokers que les contamos
tienen tres costos altísimos primero que
nada tienen que abrir una cuenta que
omiten de que básicamente es saber
quiénes son llenar un paro así dos
formularios agarrar su momento saque la
fotocopia ver de dónde viene el plata
asegurarse de que no están blanqueando
cosas por el estilo después todo eso lo
tienen que asesorar tienen que agarrar
tienen que escucharlos a ustedes saber
qué piensan de su dinero saber si son
arriesgados o no saber qué quieren hacer
con su dinero el día de mañana de vez en
cuando hacer de psicólogo porque tienen
que escuchar de que están ahorrando
mucho poco y que les gusta o no los
políticos de turno
después de eso tienen que agarrar y
pensar bueno ahora lo que este tipo
quiere como lo mezclo con lo que está en
la bolsa y después de su darle una
recomendación que va a paso una mesa y
se opera y se sigue todo eso
todo eso se cobra generalmente un
porcentaje muy chiquito del patrimonio
que se administra entonces es digamos
que se cobra un 1% mire una persona con
100 millones de pesos y asesorarles un
placer porque te vas a llevar un millón
de pesos y una persona con 100 mil pesos
y asesorarlos ya no es tan atractivo que
estás hallar mil pesos viene todo amigo
con mil pesos y le puedes cobrar 10
pesos no compras un paquete de chicles
entonces evidentemente no tiene sentido
para un broker asesorar gente con
pequeño capital entonces cómo hacen para
tener una asesoría muy personalizada y
el mismo tiempo generar ese enorme
volumen de negocios que tienen que hacer
bueno se concentran básicamente en muy
pocas personas que tienen mucho plata y
por eso las finanzas siempre se trataron
de cómo atender mejor a los más ricos
pero el resto apareció de la manera
finanzas esto que se conoce como fondos
comunes de inversión probablemente
muchos escucharon que básicamente
hicieron bueno como atendemos todo este
chiquitaje y dijeron bueno con un equipo
súper pro que maneje un tipo de
inversión y entonces no importa quién
venga y le damos un pedacito de su
inversión entonces esto importa si viene
alguien con 20 años que quiere ahorrar
parece de ocasiones o alguien de 40 que
se está comprando en su casa o alguien
de 60 que está teniendo que tener su
retiro la respuesta a todas esas
personas en la misma imagínense que iban
con todo su grupo de amigos el que le
guste la carne el vegetariano el que es
el jaco van todos juntos a mcdonald's y
cada uno pide algo distinto
evidentemente la persona que esté
tendido debe decir me la tenía
hamburguesas con suerte tener dos o tres
menús de pollos y déjame que me fije sí
que alguna ensalada de esta manera punto
es súper eficiente esto sí pero es cero
personalizado para eso aparecieron al
fin text aparecieron los asesores
automatizados y dijeron vamos a crear
una disrupción vamos a crear un nuevo
como podemos hacer para atender a toda
esta gente de manera personalizada y
distinta hicieron bueno usamos la
tecnología y decir la tecnología de
alguna manera
esto puede agarrar y traer ahorradores
buscar gente que invierte buscar gente
que no es en ningún estado de ayer y
junto con algún broker de los viejos
dinosaurios tradicionales llevarlos al
mercado aquí tiene que ser un asesor un
asesor
automatizado bueno así también tiene que
hacer tres grandes cosas primero que
nada tiene que entender que entender de
activos saber cuánto puede generar cada
activo cuánto es el riesgo que se corre
con cada activo después tienen que
tender a ustedes tienen que entender qué
perfil de riesgo tiene si ustedes le
gusta caminar a la tarde le gusta hacer
deporte extremo y ver los xgames tienen
que entender como su patrimonio si
tienen un montón de patrimonio o un muy
poquito o si es líquido o es líquido si
tiene un montón de plata un montón de
terrenos tienen que entender cuál es el
plazo en sus inversiones si están
pensando unirse vacaciones en enero o si
están pensando en cómo comprarse su casa
cuando tengan 45 años tiene que pensar
además cuál es justamente su objetivo y
aparte de todo eso tiene que tener una
metodología para invertir y hacer que
estas dos cosas se unan
con estas tres cosas y además la
posibilidad de incrementar valor como
cualquier tecnología de por ejemplo
ofrecer un servicio de educación de
hacerle entender a gente que nunca vio
un bono o una acción en su vida que es
además de darle una plataforma que no
necesite que vos tengas que ir de 8 a 1
al banco sino que puedas mirar tu
cartera a las 3 de la manera usado
cuando quiere saber si tú puedes gastar
200 pesos en un trago no
y que aparte tengo haciendo que te deje
tranquilo que te deje saber que tu
inversión es bien en miel o no todo eso
se puede conseguir mediante la
tecnología y todo eso en que se
repercute de que antes ese broker que
necesitaba de tener una persona que te
atienda que necesitaba tener una persona
que cheque documentos que necesitaba
tener una persona que esté mirando el
mercado todas esas personas no son
necesarias todo lo que hace falta es un
software corriendo en la nube y durante
un par de segundos hace todo esto te
entiende tiene una recomendación y esa
recomendación probablemente va a ser
muchísimo más barata muchísimo más
rápida e incluso muchísimo mejor que la
de todo este grupo de gente juntos
entonces ese modelo tradicional es el
modelo de atender poca gente con mucho
plata para generar volumen desaparece no
hace falta porque porque podemos generar
ese mismo en cantidad de volumen
atendiendo un montón de gente porque
ahora cuesta mucho más barato aunque
tengan muy poquito dinero cada uno
y ustedes en que les repercute todo esto
porque la pregunta es este primer me
hable de financiar la tecnología y yo
qué bueno ese pregunta que ustedes
tienen de mí yo de ahora control
ministro de mañana ahora eso no es tan
importante porque ustedes ahora pueden
empezar a pensar realmente cómo hacen
para ahorrar cómo hacen para maximizar
esos ahorros cómo hacen para cumplir su
objetivo de su primera casa de su primer
auto de su próximo viaje o de su
educación porque ahora yo no importa
cuánto sepan de finanzas no importa con
twitter o tengan ahorrado y mucho menos
importa quién conozcan dentro de
mercados hospitales todos ustedes
resisten de nueva tecnología pueden
empezar a construir su futuro hoy muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí
y
[Música]